reports are saying that the Five Nights
at Freddy's movie is going to be
approximately three hours long which to
me is absolutely insane so this tweet is
coming from Johnny Blocks he's a news
reporter for the indie horror scene he
says keep in mind that this length is
not final and an official run time will
be revealed closer to the film's release
but even the fact that it's somewhere in
the ballpark of three hours is just
mind-blowing to me I mean how long is
this game if we look at a long Play on
YouTube it's an hour and nine minutes so
that like this game can be completed in
an hour yet somehow the movie is going
to be three hours and I know obviously
there are sequels and then you have to
factor in the fact that games are always
much longer than movies because most of
the time spent in games is spent
figuring stuff out not on the story like
if you look at some of the longest games
out there and you string together all
the cutscenes they usually end up being
like one to two hours so the fact that
this Five Nights at Freddy's movie could
be three hours means that they might
have a lot up their sleeve in terms of
like stuff that they're adding to the
franchise I'm definitely going to be
surprised if that ends up happening let
me know your thoughts in the comments